I love Fox News and not just because
Tucker Carlson wants to start a race war
and I find that exciting no I love
everything about Fox and this morning I
saw them make the greatest transition in
TV news history I'm gonna play it for
you I want you to notice how they
flawlessly pivot from one news story to
the next watch carefully we are on the
cover of potato chips they see Dipper
that good morning everybody breaking
news right now from London moments ago
the British prime minister Theresa May
officially putting Russian Vladimir
Putin on notice she says Russia is
guilty in that nerve agent attack
seemless they went from potato chips to
nerve agent attacks in only five words
play it again Chuck
oh yeah need some dip with that get it
because dip is where chips go but also
Russia tried to murder a man now could
Bill Hemmer have said nothing before
transitioning from chips to attempted
assassination sure it would have been
very very easy perhaps even the
obviously correct thing to do but that's
why Fox is great they're never satisfied
they're always working
improving take their slogan it used to
be fair and balanced that's not gonna
work perfectly captured say John Stossel
dressing up like a homeless man to
demonstrate that charity is wrong it
just fits but Fox decided to get rid of
that slogan not because it was in any
way flawed but because they wanted
something even better
and after a blissful few months with
most-watched most trusted they're now
switching it up once again to drumroll
please Fox News real News real honest
opinion whoa whoa you know Fox is really
real because they say it two times
compare that to MSNBC their slogan is
and I'm not making this up this is who
we are
I mean come on don't admit that it's
when losers say when they've accepted
that they'll always be miserable MSNBC
is your drunk uncle stumbling around the
family reunion his shirts not buttoned
right he smells like Jim Beam he looks
you dead in the eyes and says this is
who we are but not Fox their new slogan
is great for two reasons one it lets you
know their news is real two it lets you
know that other news must not be real
but in a classy subtle way it's genius
in fact it inspired me to come up with a
new slogan for the opposition the
opposition the late night show that
doesn't hurt cats
does that mean other late night shows do
hurt cat whoops to say not me I'm just
saying the opposition is the late night
show that does not hurt cats
isn't that right Kobe oh hi there Jordan
I'm proud to say that I work for the
late night show that does not hurt cats
we're not saying other late night shows
do but is that their slogan
I mean if other late night shows weren't
secretly punting cats on the Reg
wouldn't they say so does Trevor Noah
throw at a be in a tight spiral into an
open furnace while Seth Meyers shovels
calicoes off the side of his private
yacht Trevor and Seth laughing the whole
time ha ha ha uh shirring cat after cat
into cat hell is that what they do yes
that's exactly what they do tip nope Tim
Timmy though we're not saying that we
are saying that we are not Tim you
literally told me to stand here and say
that oh no I did not no all we're saying
is that we don't hurt cats that if any
other late-night show wants to claim
that they don't hurt cats either well
they better have some damn good lawyers
because that is copyright infringement
[Music]